now I guess Rose button just a piece of
a jigsaw puzzle piece
say my name Tyler Durden we're the same
person that's right
the never was arrived there never was an
errand no swing way service please Avada
Kedavra
[Music]
a boy's best friend is his mother Missy
and they don't know when they're saying
she wouldn't even have
surprise what's matter Sydney look like
you've seen a ghost
[Music]
in 1966 and defriend escaped from
Shawshank Prison
I'm sorry about Union
[Music]
damn you
real janji he's already dead
this plenty of John Jesus rusted fine
birthday Nick what is this it's your
birthday present
[Music]
and faced with an intense truth a
child's mind may fracture creating
disassociated identities you are one of
his personalities you've been here for
two years a patient of this institution
your name is Andrew bladers 67th patient
of Ashe cliff is you
[Music]
you're gonna tell him silent brain is
feeble Dondo head the other hand I took
a souvenir what's in the Bob the
greatest trick the devil ever pulled
I'm a theatrical panache Kobayashi was
convincing the world he didn't exist
[Music]
morning doc guy party party party Marty